somebody hands you a data set like this
and this could be this could be
literally anything this could be the
value of a stock that's changing over
time this could be the position of a
robot you can use your imagination
taking or whatever you do and work for
yourself it doesn't matter now
you're given this and you are asked to
predict what this value is going to be
at some future time that's not shown on
the graph so you look at this thing and
you say okay in the beginning it's
pretty much just chaos I don't know what
I would do there but maybe as it goes
it's it's getting a little periodic and
maybe I can exploit that somehow you
might be able to make some headway with
this but the the punchline is it's not
it's not going to be trivial to do this
so now what if instead you you happen to
know that you could take this time
series and decompose it into these eight
component parts if you if you look
closely at each of these it's basically
a sinusoid that's that has some decaying
exponential envelope to it and
predicting what any one of these is
going to do at some future time seems
like a much simpler task so the question
that should be coming up in your head at
this point is where on earth did I get
these component functions from and how
do you figure out what the what the
weighting is or the recipe to get back
the original data so these are the types
of problems that got me really
interested in this field it turns out
that you can do this with linear algebra
despite the fact that nothing on here
looks like a straight line but we're
gonna we're gonna look at some fun stuff
like this and hopefully you'll leave
with some inspiration to go and keep
digging up more of this material for
yourself before I further the ideas that
I'm gonna share with you today I learned
through these really excellent courses
taught by professor Stephen Boyd and
Sanjay law at Stanford University these
guys have created a tremendous resource
in that they put their their course
lectures and notes online for free as
well as books on the material
yeah please capture these links I'll
show them again on my final slide and I
can you know post them online if there's
any sort of resources for the follow up
but everybody here please check this out
if you're interested it's it's a
tremendous resource so Who am I and how
did I get so excited about this why why
do I care why did I put all this energy
into making a talk on this so I am one
of the first engineers at a company
called spry health at spry we have made
the first fda-cleared wearable wristband
that monitors vital signs continuously
for people who are living with chronic
illnesses so my job as part of the
algorithms team is to take the raw
physiological information that we get
from our sensors and use that to
estimate what are the vital signs of the
wearer
at that particular moment in time and
then on top of this we our aim is to
build up this enormous and unprecedented
data set of vital signs through days and
months and then use that information to
predict whether or not somebody is at
the risk of returning to the hospital or
the emergency room in the work that I do
it's essentially impossible for me to
pick up a research paper and get through
it without needing to understand at some
level the properties of vectors and
matrices but more interestingly to me
than that is that if you whatever
discipline you work in if you have a
problem and you can cram and Bend and
stretch this thing to look like this
then the only thing you need to
are the properties of this matrix a and
the rest will sort itself out you can
take ideas from finance and use them to
solve whatever you're doing and maybe
fluid mechanics problems like this come
up literally everywhere and we could
spend you know days just going through
examples but I figured let's just start
with a few to to get warmed up so if we
are in classical mechanics we could have
a rocket or some object the vector X
could be a list of a few forces acting
at different points on the object the
vector Y can be a list of the the total
resulting forces or torques and the
matrix a then contains all of the
information about the geometry that's
specific to that that object we can
switch gears entirely and go into
something for business operations so you
can have your vector X now representing
the the price of all of the component
parts that you use Y can be the prices
of all of your finished products or you
know how much you need to charge for
those and a then the rows of a are the
sorts of recipes for each of your
products and this becomes a kind of Bill
of Materials switching let's see we
could work
keyboard we can switch fields again this
time to statistics and this one's a
little more subtle
so here what becomes your X vector from
an autoregressive model is actually the
coefficients for each time leg you'll
notice the A's are now the vector on the
right y is the output of the model
itself so this is now your time series
of data and your matrix a is this kind
of weird concept where each row is a
stacked time window out of your data
what I really like about this example in
addition to the the one I should at the
beginning is it emphasizes that we don't
just have to talk about straight lines
when we were doing linear algebra if
you've worked with AR models before you
know these things can can have all kinds
of crazy shapes and behavior so so we're
not we're not stuck with lines and we
can generalize this further I have made
absolutely no requirements about how you
get the numbers that are in your matrix
a these can come from absolutely hideous
functions depending on what field you're
in they can be you know Bessel functions
of the 50th order it doesn't matter as
if it's the elements that are in your
matrix as long as the weights that tell
you how to mix those functions are first
order then you can still work with this
framework so before diving in to some of
the specific topics I want to cover a
little bit of a disclaimer this field is
so deep and has so much richness that
there's no possible way to get through
it in a 30-minute talk so the way that
I'm going to cover as much as I can is
by being completely irresponsible with
my math I'm not gonna prove anything I'm
gonna wave my arms a lot just trust me
on it everything that you see here is a
you can google search and find proofs of
it very quickly this is all well
documented and on top of that I put
together a series of Python notebooks
that
post a link to on my final slide which
goes into more examples that I wanted to
fit in but didn't have time you can play
with you know the source code how I
generate some of the figures that I'm
gonna show so just know that that's
coming up okay so with that preamble out
of the way let's you know start dusting
off some of our neurons from our you
know classes that we took a long time
ago
the first topic that I want to start
with is matrix rank so as a refresher
the rank of a matrix is a property it's
an integer and that number tells you
what is the largest grouping of rows or
columns that you can take and have it
form a linearly independent set it's
easiest to explain that in example
so with this matrix that I've shown here
I'm gonna use numpy arrays for
everything no matter how much I want to
and how hard I try I will not be able to
take these first two rows and scale them
and add them together in some way that
produces this third row so these three
vectors form a linearly independent set
and the rank of this matrix numpy
cheerfully tells us is 3 now the the
rank has to be less than the number of
rows or columns are equal to that so as
soon as we add another row to this
matrix it's this set will no longer be
linearly independent in this case you
can see I can take two times the first
row plus the second row plus the third
row I get the fourth row so the rank
stays the same at 3 and we would say
this is not a full rank matrix because
of that and you know flipping rows and
columns it doesn't matter so as soon as
we introduce some idea that there's
redundant information in this matrix
immediately what can come to your mind
is there's an opportunity for
compression I'll demonstrate how this is
going to work with a pretty contrived
example but say that you have a matrix
that you want to put on a computer
this thing has a million rows but only
two columns and the second column is
exactly double the first column now it
would be it would be silly to store all
of this in memory when you can
automatically save half of the space by
just storing the first column and
remembering if you ever need to index
into the second column just multiply by
two so I've shown here how we can
express that idea in sort of a matrix
equation notation you can take a and you
can factor it into these two two things
and it's a you know a pretty small
matrix but it's matrix this idea of
course generalizes and it turns out any
matrix if you know the rank can be split
into two smaller matrices whose shape is
determined by the rank and our
mathematician friends have given us a
whole host of tools that will give you
different types of these matrices so
this is absolutely possible now if you
go through pretty simple arithmetic to
calculate how many numbers do you have
to store you find out you need m times
and numbers for the original matrix but
if your rank R is much smaller than
either of those dimensions you can have
a very considerable savings in how much
you you need to store and somewhat
amusingly if you ask the question how
many floating-point operations or
multiplications does it take to multiply
some vector X by this matrix the math is
exactly the same you you have M times n
flops for for the full matrix and if
your rank is low you can save quite a
bit of you know time and efficiency by
using the the factored form
okay starting to feel a little bit warm
juices are going the next subject is
another one that I think everybody would
have seen in kind of an introductory
linear algebra course this is gonna be I
give vectors and eigen values who here
remember is going through lots of
loose-leaf paper writing out a
polynomial and finding the zeros
I hear chuckles in hand so okay I'm not
alone on this I can't count how many
trees I must have gone through I
certainly never had any idea why I was
doing all this it turns out to be very
useful okay I'll use a picture just to
remind us all what these things are
suppose you start with a vector X in
some space and you multiply that with a
square matrix this has the effect of
transforming it and in general if you
start with this X here you'll end up
with a new vector that probably points
in some other direction in space for any
matrix there are a few special
directions that if you transform those
vectors you end up with an output that
is a scaled version of the vector you
started with written as an equation we
have a V equals lambda V where lambda is
the scaling factor and these things turn
out to come up so often we give them a
fancy name we use eigen which means same
and so you have V as the eigenvector and
lambda as the eigenvalue there are quite
a few situations where these become
useful but the one that kind of grabbed
my attention the most when I was
learning this it comes up in systems
that evolve over time so within this
context X our vector is going to
represent a list of properties that
define a system at some moment in time
these could be parameters in a
statistical model or in physics a good
one is it could be the position velocity
and acceleration of some object
the matrix a is contains all the
information about how you update the
state of your system from one time to
the next time step it's it's possible to
write out an expression for the state at
any time given the state at the
beginning time and the relationship has
entirely made of terms that have this
structure with one of the eigenvectors
and a coefficient that is an eigenvalue
raised to a power that grows with time
the ellipses in this are hiding some
really ugly terms but those also you
know end up having the structure there's
factorials and binomial coefficients and
things and I just wanted to highlight
this here so I find this completely
amazing
you know we introduced eigenvalues and
eigenvectors as these kind of you know
funny geometric concepts and here they
show up in a sistah or in when we're
talking about how things evolve it
didn't have to be that way and beyond
that because of the particular structure
here there turned out to be only a few
simple things that can happen so we can
have Augen values with a magnitude of 1
in which case those terms in your
expression don't do anything as time
advances this you can think of this as a
kind of steady state behavior you can
have I can value Sue's magnitude is less
than 1 and as time passes those terms
dampen out and go to zero and if you're
in you know some sort of mechanical
system this tends to represent kind of
stability things get calmer over time
and then of course the third is if your
eigen value has a magnitude greater than
one as more time passes the weight of
those terms is going to explode to
infinity and this you would think of as
kind of an unstable system one detail
even if all of the entries in your
matrix a are real you can still have
complex
sigan values and eigenvectors and the
way that manifests is that you have a
periodic oscillation but the asymptotic
behavior is exactly the same so a fun
way to play with this idea and to see it
in practice comes up with Markov chains
I have people here worked with Markov
chains before just to get a sense I see
a couple of hands so for people who
haven't seen this before it's a I think
a pretty straightforward idea imagine
that you have at any point in time you
can be in one of a few discrete states
and then there's some probability on
every time step given what state you're
in now that you switch to a different
one of the states and that's about it
if you pick one at random and then you
do coin flips and you you know just
write out which state you pass through
over time you'll get it you know it a
sequence like this and we would call
that a Markov chain and this whole thing
is a Markov process so I picked you know
a situation that might come up you have
an employee who can either be working
thinking or not doing anything and a
classic question that would come up with
a model like this is what is the
probability or what percent of the time
is my employee doing what I want him to
do Markov chains are nice because they
are a completely linear process here are
our state vector is a list of the
probabilities at a particular time that
you are in each of the states and the
transition matrix has a nice
interpretation each entry is the
probability that you in one time step
that you switch from the jafe state into
the ice state okay when I was in high
school I had a particularly boring
hamster who had a very set routine it
would sleep it would wake up and run on
its wheel and then it would eat and then
we go back to sleep and it would
repeat this ad nauseum so it's a simple
task to write out the Markov process for
my hamster look something like this
and what I've done here is I've just
written out this is the the transition
matrix that you would have for a process
like this so a question to you guys what
types of behavior would you expect to
see in a state vector for this process
you can just shout things out exactly so
one one big one is that every three time
steps you would expect to come back to
where you started and there's actually
one more that's a little more subtle and
if anybody you can see it so can you say
a bit louder so so yes with the so just
reminding that the interpretation of the
vector is that it's probability so you
can have if you start that all three
states with an equal probability of
occupation then it turns out that will
remain constant as you apply the update
matrix so if we go to numpy and we ask
it to give back the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of this matrix we can see
two things right away so here we have an
eigenvalue of 1 which that's going to
represent this kind of unchanging
behavior and this value is associated
with an eigenvector that has equal
entries in all three states so this is
that that second behavior I mentioned
the other two eigenvalues are have
complex values and these are a complex
conjugate pair so both of these vectors
turn out to be in this periodic rotation
through the states in the same direction
so I threw together just another type of
transition process and here we get back
that we have all real eigenvalues one of
them is equal to 1 the other two are
less than 1 so just looking at this can
you can you make a guess as to what this
system is going to do over time yeah
so that is we're gonna see any any part
of the initial state that's associated
with these two vectors or that's
constructed from these two vectors is
going to go away what's going to be left
is a vector that has all of its weight
in one of the states so we should see a
kind of convergence and if we if we run
the simulation forward that's exactly
what we see all of the weight that
starts in components 2 and 3 goes to 0
component 1 maxes out so Markov chains
as the example that I chose because they
deal with probabilities turn out to have
a property they will always have an
eigen value exactly equal to 1 and this
idea is one of the fundamental
principles of Google's PageRank
algorithm so whether you like it or not
you're actually interacting with this
every single day which i think is cool
for the for the final topic that I
wanted to cover today I wanted to go
with something that isn't typically seen
in a basic linear algebra class so it'll
be new but this I think is one of the
most powerful ideas in the field it
enables you to prove all kinds of things
very very easily and it has way more
applications than there's time for today
so it's called the singular value
decomposition and I'll I'll introduce it
with a bit of a story it's a fun fact if
you take the vectors that comprise a
sphere and you transform them now with
any matrix a it doesn't matter the shape
the resulting output that you get is an
ellipse and as an ellipse
you can define it by a set of principal
axes that are mutually perpendicular or
orthogonal to each other now what's
amazing is if you take these principal
axes and you ask the question what were
the input vectors that mapped onto them
though is also turn out to give you a
set of mutually orthogonal vectors and
it turns out that they actually create a
basis for the input and output space as
a reminder you can think of a basis as
if you were to take your Cartesian axes
and kind of rotate them so we have some
flexibility in how we scale things so to
make it nice and clean we define these
vectors V and U for the the two bases so
that they all have a length of one and
then we'll introduce the scaling
coefficient Sigma so that the math works
out that when you transform one of the
inputs you get the output so these
Sigma's are going to end up being called
singular values which is where the name
comes from
now we can do is we can start with this
equation for one of the vectors and we
can actually group all the vectors
together stacking them horizontally into
a matrix and that gives us a structure
that looks like this one so we have a V
equals u big Sigma now big Sigma is a
diagonal matrix it's almost all zeros
except this main diagonal we put those
scaling coefficients on and the one last
step is we'll just invoke this fact that
all of those input and output vectors
are a mutually orthogonal so these
vectors v and u are what are called
orthogonal matrices which means that if
you multiply them by the transpose they
essentially cancel out so that lets us
rearrange this in one step and we've
just shown that any single matrix a can
be written with the special form where
you have an orthogonal matrix a diagonal
matrix and an orthogonal matrix this is
called the singular value decomposition
and like I said it shows up a lot so one
of one of the ways in particular is I
mentioned there were you know lots of
algorithms that could give you this low
rank factorization for compression this
turns out to be an easy one you just
group these two and now you've got your
two matrices okay so of the applications
for this thing the one that for me I
thought was the most motivating or most
exciting when I saw it is this idea of
the pseudo inverse the other reason is I
think this is extremely powerful and but
when we do interviews with candidates
that spry it's something that very few
people seem to have come across before
so hopefully this is something I can
share with all of you and it will have a
great impact in the problems that you
solve okay say for this for this set up
I'll use an example from like mechanical
engineering we have some kind of heat
conductive plate and we put some thermal
limiters on it
this could be you know computer
processor is that as you run them more
they dissipate power into the board and
then we have a couple of sensors that
are placed on the board to measure what
the temperature is and you know the
classic question you would have here is
given the measurement of the temperature
how much power are we dissipating from
our processors the kind of common rule
of thumb wisdom is I need to have as
many equations as I have unknowns in a
problem like this that would translate
mathematically to having a be a square
matrix and then to solve for the
unknowns we would need to have a be
invertible and then we could switch the
sides and we get out an estimate of what
our what our own unknown vector X is
this is okay but it has some problems
for instance say my budget gets bigger
and now I can put a force sensor on
there this like intuitively this should
only give me more information about my
problem but it kind of breaks our math
because we don't know how to invert a
matrix when it's not square and that
force sensor makes our Y vector longer
which means you have an extra row and a
and now it's not square the other
possibility is maybe one of our sensors
breaks or maybe they're expensive and we
we can't afford to put enough of them on
there and it would be much nicer to have
a best-guess or to say something rather
than just going up her hand and saying
you know this can't be done so the the
singular value decomposition gives us a
very very quick way to get an answer so
we just we invoke the decomposition and
then if you look at this thing for a
moment you might see that if we multiply
by this thing which it you know it just
ends up being a matrix you can go
through some very simple algebra and all
of this stuff just cancels out I think
let's see I forgot to transpose on there
so this this new matrix is so
significant that it gets a really fancy
name it's called the more penrose
pseudoinverse and there is just a single
line numpy command that will give this
to you and it has some very beautiful
interpretations so if your a matrix is
tall then the pseudo-inverse gives you
the least squares solution it minimizes
the sum of squares error and if you
haven't worked with least squares before
this is this picture of finding a best
fit line where you don't necessarily hit
all of your data points but you you end
up being close to them in the other case
if you have a wide matrix then the
pseudo-inverse
you at you have multiple solutions in
this case that are exact but the pseudo
inverse will give you the one with the
smallest sum of squares of the entries
of the vector X and so in a polynomial
regression case this would be finding
the curve that goes through all your
data points but you know has the least
wild swings in it or sir to the lowest
order okay
so we'll apply this idea to a real
problem and this is this is how my class
at Stanford opened and blew my mind so
for this imagine that we have something
like a magnetic hard disk that has a
head that can move in a 2-dimensional
plane and we can steer it by you know
tuning two inputs these could be
voltages or currents or something so
what we'd like to do is be able to move
from any starting position to a new
target and we'd like to arrive there
smoothly and you know sort of in a time
that we can control so systems like this
and very commonly mechanical systems
turn out to be well modeled with what
are called linear dynamic systems so
this is just this is a couple of
matrices and vectors
X here is again it's it's some sort of
internal states it's not something we
necessarily measure directly but we
might be able to you know starting from
our original equations know what those
things are
U is whatever the inputs we put in that
we can control and then Y is what we
physically observe so it's kind of the
naive first approach for a problem like
this is let's figure out you know the
solution where X isn't changing over
time and Y is the Y that we want and you
can get this by just you know doing some
arithmetic to to rearrange this and it
turns out that I built a really terrible
harddrive because when I just go
directly to the point that I'm trying to
reach my arm completely overshoots and
it swings back and forth and it vibrates
for a while and it takes a whole bunch
of time for this to kind of dampen out
but eventually it does reach the target
that I is set for it okay now let's
let's do the fancy singular value
approach that we just learned so if we
if we take the linear dynamic dynamic
system and unroll it as a recursion we
get kind of a scary looking thing that
gives us our final position at any time
as a function of all of the inputs
leading up to that time
and okay now this this looks gross but
if you you know take a breath step back
you know relax for a second you realize
this is just y equals mu this is a
simple matrix equation and that means we
can use a pseudo inverse and find the U
with the smallest sum of squares that
gets us to Y at the time that we want so
if we run this simulation the the inputs
that we get out are these completely
bizarre things and I challenge you to
come up with those on your own but if
you look at what the position of our our
mechanical arm does it kind of you know
wobbles around for a bit and then at the
time 800 seconds that I chose for this
it locks in exactly where I wanted it to
go and it stays there for all future
times no overshoot and it turns out I
can make the
arrival time arbitrarily small and if
this will still work there's a trade-off
that you might need to use bigger input
voltages to get there but you can do it
you know whenever you want okay so right
on cue I'd like to you know just review
several topics that we've covered so we
introduced with all these examples of
where linear algebra algebra comes up
and we said you know we're dealing with
situations that can look much more
complicated than straight lines we
talked about the rank of a matrix and
how you can exploit that for compression
efficiency we went into eigenvalues and
eigenvectors and we looked at markov
chains and how you can make statements
and predictions about how systems will
evolve over time and then we introduced
this new idea of the singular value
decomposition and we showed a fun
example with the hard disk there so
that's that's the end of my talk I'd
like to leave this slide up just so that
people can have access to this spry is
always hiring and we're looking for
people like you so please reach out to
me if you're curious and want to learn
more I'll be around for the full
conference I mentioned I had a notebook
with more of these examples that link is
right here these are the Stanford
resources and then some some extra
topics if you you know this stuff and
you want to you know go deeper into
something new so with that thank you
very much for your time and attention